how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and right now all the hype in the
mcu is about
two different projects of course
spider-man 3 because of
all of the reports and rumors attached
to it but also of course
one division because we just had the
release of the first two episodes last
friday and we're getting episode three
tomorrow slash
tonight at 1am pacific time and what's
really cool about the hype around these
two projects is
they're actually going to connect to
each other one division is going to tie
heavily into what happens in spider-man
3 and from there
the events of one division and
spider-man 3 are going to tie into
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness and this has actually been
confirmed by none other than the marvel
studios president kevin feige now we've
known for a while that want a vision
would tie into doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness elizabeth olsen
was even shooting scenes for doctor
strange 2 before
production for the movie got put on hold
due to coven 19.
so we knew that but then kevin feige
during the investor day said that
spider-man 3 is going to connect with
one division
and doctor strange 2. and now we have a
new report about something
really cool that could happen in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
this is coming from daniel richmond's
patreon where he says
doctor strange will fight two avengers
in multiverse of madness the scarlet
witch and
an evil version of captain america he
also says that kevin feige wants
jennifer lawrence's mystique
in the movie as well not sure about
mystique that could be used for many
different things in multiverse of
madness but let's talk about the scarlet
witch and an evil captain america taking
on doctor strange
now there have been a lot of suspicions
that the scarlet witch will be evil by
the end of one division
and paul bettany did reveal that towards
the end of one division there is going
to be
a huge battle that's going to have more
cgi
than avengers end game had think about
that for a second more cgi
than avengers end game that means these
battles are going to be
absolutely insane and they're most
likely going to involve a lot of
magic so whoever wanda is going to be
fighting has to be
extremely strong because she is already
most likely one of the most powerful
characters in the mcu if not the
strongest and most of you know my theory
by now i think mephisto is the main
villain and i also think that agatha
harkness is a villain as well
two characters who are highly
well-versed in witchcraft and if these
are the two characters that she will be
fighting at the end of one division
there is a good chance that yes she
could turn evil
and maybe not even turning evil but just
not caring anymore
so perhaps she goes about doing things
her own way from then on out and doctor
strange might have a problem with that
now as for an evil captain america we
did get reports last week
stating that chris evans could return to
the mcu in fact they said that he's in
final negotiations to return
for two different movies where he won't
be the lead it will more likely be
cameos and this will certainly be a very
interesting cameo
an evil captain america fighting doctor
strange now in the multiverse of madness
anything is possible an evil captain
america is possible
especially if you consider the fact that
by the end of one division
wanda will most likely have figured out
how her reality warping powers work
so it probably won't be that hard for
her to create a reality where an evil
captain america exists and then bring
him
into the normal real reality and then
it'll be up to doctor strange to send
him back so this will most likely happen
quite a few different times there's
probably going to be a lot of characters
that we see that don't belong to our
actual timeline but
other timelines and other universes this
is why the multiverse will be
and madness in doctor strange too
because of what happened in one division
and then of course in spider-man 3.
based off of all of the reports and
rumors that we heard spider-man 3 is
going to consist of characters from at
least
three different universes and the reason
they could be all colliding into one
universe is because of the events that
will happen
in one division it looks like wanda
could be creating multiple different
realities and then fusing some together
whether on purpose or not
now again this will most likely only be
a quick cameo from chris evans if he
does indeed appear in multiverse of
madness
there's not really much he can do to
fight against doctor strange doctor
strange is just way more powerful
but perhaps if the scarlet witch gives
him a little bit of magic maybe he might
actually be a problem but do you think
the scarlet witch will be
evil in multiverse of madness if i hear
anything else i'll let you know so be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest mcu news be sure to
give the video a like and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof
me